The bridge. Uh, in order
to get to the bridge,
I want to go back and just say
a few more things about, uh,
voyages and about crane, uh, in general,
uh, in, uh, Crane's letter to, um,
the distressed editor of poetry
magazine, Harriet Monroe, uh,
that pros, uh, uh,
selection included in the,
the back of your book crane defense,
his palm app,
Melville's tomb, and,
uh, specifically defends,
uh, well, uh, what he calls his,
uh, recourse to the logic of metaphor. Um,
what, what does the logic of
metaphor mean for crane? Well,
um, he, um,
distinguishes a,
his criteria for Monroe's on
page nine 68. Uh, you know,
he says, my palm may well be a
elliptical and actually obscure,
but in your criticism,
uh,
you've stated your objections in terms
that allow me the privilege of claiming
your ideas and ideals as theoretically,
at least quite outside the issues
of my own aspirations. And he says,
to put it more plainly,
as a poet,
I may very possibly be more interested
in the so called illogical impingements
of the connotations of,
well, that's a misprint. I,
it should be words on the consciousness
and their combinations and interplay in
metaphor in this basis.
Then I am interested in the preservation
of their logically rigid significations.
Uh, crane is talking here about,
um, well, uh,
putting a kind of priority in his
poetry on connotation a over denotation.
Uh,
he's interested in the ways words
relate to and through other words,
uh,
before or in addition to the
ways in which they relate to,
uh, the things of the
world in this sense. Uh,
crane,
uh,
well introduces us to
a sense of poetry as,
um, as a linguistic
environment that, uh, uh,
is constructed through words,
uh, relating among themselves,
uh, in ways that play upon our, um, uh,
imagination systems of
association, uh, that in,
in effect our contribution to,
uh,
complete the thought,
all of which supposes and seeks a kind
of special intimacy with us as readers,
um, gives us a work to do. Um,
I suggested that the sea is a kind of
figure or metaphor in cranes work for this
linguistic space.
Um,
an imaginative space to which we are
summoned in a poem like App Melville's
Tomb. Uh, he's because he's
concerned with specifically, um,
how messages are transported,
um,
with, uh, the, uh, um, uh,
well what he calls the dice
have drowned men's bones. Um,
you can understand the, the, uh, the
poem is an allergy for Melville. Uh,
it's also a about reading Melville,
uh,
and getting his message,
that is reaching back into the
past and becoming for Melville,
the kind of reader that crane
himself seeks a as he describes it,
uh, in, um, uh, his letter to Monroe.
Uh,
in talking about voyages to,
I suggested that the,
our voyage is three rather.
The third section of the poem,
I,
I suggested that the image
of infinite con sang Gwyneth
was a impart an image of this linguistic
mixing and promiscuity that crane is
interested in, uh, in,
in poetry in this poem.
Uh,
the mixing of words in poetry
is analogized to the mixing of,
uh,
body of bodies of lovers.
Love here is also like death,
uh,
because it's a shattering
experience, uh, through which, uh,
the self is remade a and changed,
um,
with and through another,
uh, this is a process
of transformation. Uh,
it's one that crane costs Trans
member meant, um, which is,
uh, a way of evoking, not so
much a sharing of identity,
but rather some kind of exchange of it,
uh,
which is an experience
of the self changed, uh,
and the self redeemed,
uh, in, in cranes eyes.
This is exactly what
the wasteland, um, uh,
contemplates and draws
back from, uh, doesn't, uh,
embrace turns away from
it's what in Crane, uh,
love promises.
It's what poetry song promises.
Uh, the, uh, the space of
the palm, which is, uh,
like as crane imagines
that, uh, a space of love
is set apart from ordinary
life. Um, you, you, uh,
uh, Mike, uh, contrast the
kind of song and singing, uh,
that you find in this palm with
Elliot's Love Song for Prufrock,
uh,
crane recovers in this poem,
a kind of heroic blank first,
uh,
the medium of heroic drama,
and uses it for the speech of a poet
lover who celebrates the power of sound to
make its own sense through
the affirming force of desire.
Uh, he imagines this again, as a kind of
resurrection of some kind. What do you,
what he talks about is what has
to happen after the wasteland.
Uh,
in this sense,
a crane is talking about some
kind of passage through death.
Uh, and you can understand
that death as cranes,
admission as I suggested last time of the,
um,
uh, illusory nature of, um,
uh, rhetoric, uh, of, um, of love,
a itself of the power of a desire
which,
uh,
crane is always realistic about you.
You could say,
um, the poem voyages, uh,
treats its theme is really
the triumph of desire, uh,
even in defeat. Uh, that's also, uh,
the, the, um,
the theme of that Melville's tomb and
it's the grand theme of the bridge.
The bridge is cranes. Great
Poem, uh, about America.
Uh, we'll, uh, let me
bring up a picture of him.
This is a,
this is crane in 1927 or 28.
It's an unclear exactly when the
photo was taken by Walker Evans,
a great American photographer
and cranes friend on top of 'em,
one 10, Columbia Heights where crane
lived, uh, in view of Manhattan.
And, uh, the bridge, the Brooklyn Bridge,
the bridge is cranes.
A great poem about America or
about the idea of American.
I'll say more about what
that means in a moment. Uh,
and it's a reply, uh,
self consciously. So,
uh, to the wasteland. Uh,
I suggested that the shortness
of the wasteland was a,
in some ways, um, uh,
kind of argument against epic,
uh, in the modern world, uh,
uh, argument, uh,
about the impossibility of epic vision
in a culture which lacks a shared myths,
shared symbols,
a against this,
this lack a crane proposes,
uh, the bridge, uh,
the Brooklyn Bridge as a kind of
central organizing symbol, uh,
for modern culture.
Um,
the, uh, uh, this, this is a picture
of the bridge being built, um, uh,
in the 19th century. Uh,
it's important that as crane,
uh, looks at the bridge, uh, as a,
as a modern symbol that we remember
that it wasn't built in 1920 when I've,
I've forgotten now the, the year in
which it is a, but it was a, at least,
I think 60 years old at this point.
And you can see when, um, uh,
Roebling bridge, uh, was first
created. There's no Manhattan skyline
for it to reach to a, when crane, um, um,
turns to the bridge as
a symbol of the modern,
he's already looking back to an
earlier vision of the modern, uh,
if you like. Uh, and
in doing so, he is, uh,
joining many other American artists.
This is a photograph,
uh, by a Walker Evans, uh, who, who took,
uh, many images, uh, of
the, uh, the bridge, um,
with its cables and a Gothic Arches,
all of which play into crane's
palms and complex ways.
Uh,
this is
the, the very great poem,
one of many Pa poem painting,
uh, by, uh, uh, Joseph Stella that, uh,
appears in the Yale Gallery,
a fantastic work, uh,
one that crane hadn't seen actually
when he began, uh, the bridge,
but which in all sorts of ways, um, uh,
is, is, uh,
Moni us with, with his
vision, including, um,
the ways in which, uh, the,
uh, sublime vision, uh,
that it offers, uh, includes, uh,
darkness. Uh, and, and I
would have to say, ah, okay,
uh, perhaps, uh, a frightening or, or, um,
um, sinister elements. Um,
it is a,
also importantly,
a moment in American art
when artists like a Stella,
uh,
like
a crane or interested,
uh, here's a Joseph Marin,
uh, uh, with another image. This
one painted from the bridge,
uh,
are in
which artists are creating a
kind of an idiom that involves,
includes abstraction, uh, shows us, uh,
images of the world in
realist representation that
are being transformed into,
uh, something, uh, semi
abstract and symbolic.
A crane is, is very much
involved in the same kind of, uh,
activity as these artists.
These are more images, uh, uh,
from Evans. Uh, these of course
shot from underneath the bridge and,
and showing it, uh, uh,
as a kind of abstract,
uh, form a rising, uh, into, uh,
uh, the New York skyline. Um,
this is, uh, this is the title page of,
of cranes a poem as it appeared in the,
uh,
uh, black son, uh, addition
a limited edition, uh,
in Paris in 1930. Uh, it's, uh, uh,
first publication followed shortly
thereafter by publication in New York
Crane took the Brooklyn
Bridge, uh, as, um,
as a kind of symbol of a structure.
The structure of spiritual
action as he understood it.
Underpinning American history,
it seemed to him to embody an idea that
he saw variously embodied in American
history. Uh, for crane.
American history is a
series of new world visions,
uh, all of them, uh,
versions or avatars of what
he also calls it Lantis.
Uh, the city sunk beneath the
waves in platonic Nif, uh,
that promises to return,
uh,
in return us to some kind
of redeemed community.
Uh,
Atlanta says cranes name for a kind
of promised relation to the world.
Uh,
that's been a glimpse but also
lost a to aim at Atlantis,
uh, as the poem does. And as
crane says, American history does,
uh, is to go interestingly, confusingly,
simultaneously into the
past and into the future,
uh,
to rescue or recover something from
history promised for the future,
uh, in to bring that future into
being crane understands, uh,
the mythic work of the poem,
his poem,
a as a kind of act of
a one that has this kind of chronological
mission of going back into the past
and forward into the future.
The title page here. Uh, you can't
make it out, but it's, uh, in,
um, uh, uh,
clear in your anthology carries a,
an epigraph from the book of Job,
uh,
from going to and fro in the earth
and from walking up and down in it.
Uh, the, the, um, um,
epigraph from job introduces these two
motions as being essential to a crane's
imagination in the poem that is
going to and fro back and forth.
And by going up and down, uh, you can see,
uh, these two motions,
uh, in fact, um, uh,
easily, uh, visual izable in
the form of the bridge itself,
which drives, it's pylons
that into the river, uh,
and rises up in these gothic
structures in order to carry,
uh,
people back and forth across the river.
Uh, the, uh, epigraph is
also a kind of joke, uh,
because crane wrote this poem,
a like job tramping around,
uh, across, uh, the, uh,
the northeast, uh, from, uh,
one apartment or House to
another, uh, or one couch,
uh, to uh, another, uh, and uh,
wrote it in Europe,
uh, and uh, California,
uh, and elsewhere. Um,
him self crane, being,
um, uh, um, without, um, uh,
secure, uh, station, uh, in, in, um, uh,
the poem, uh, in the,
the writing of the poem,
a crane's, um, interest
in the poem, uh, in,
uh, Hobos, uh, and marginals, uh,
of a, of many kinds, uh,
as well as with pioneers and
other kinds of travelers, uh,
all, um, represent, um,
uh, figures, uh,
of spiritual questers who are,
um,
in a sense without a station in life,
but rather in motion as, um, uh,
crane himself was the,
um,
this is the table of contents of the poem.
Uh,
it's helpful I think to, uh, uh,
look at it because it's
confusing. Um, it, it,
uh, the poem consists in
this, uh, pro, um, which I'll,
I'll talk about in a few moments.
Uh,
when crane actually dedicates as long
poem actually dedicates as poem to the
Brooklyn Bridge is if you could dedicate
a poem to the bridge to an object,
uh, a first section called Ave
Maria, which is spoken by Columbus,
Columbus,
not on his way to the new world,
but rather on his way back.
Uh, he speaks to us, uh,
on his way back.
Uh,
and it introduces the theme of,
uh,
carrying the message or the
vision forward into the future.
Um, the question of, you know,
how to retrieve or recover, um,
uh, the, uh, the vision
of the new world, uh,
is initially introduced there.
Uh,
then there's a section called
Pow Hatton's daughter, uh,
which refers to Pocahontas,
uh, invokes, um,
a, a, um, a vision of
the American continent,
uh, through a series of poems. Uh,
the Harbord Dance Van
Winkle, uh, the, the river,
the dance in Indiana, uh, which all, uh,
explore various moments in the history of,
um, the, uh, um, uh, um,
conquering of the continent.
Uh,
there's a section called
cutty Sark, uh, which, um, uh,
introduces us to a, um, um,
a drunken,
a visionary,
a sailor in a bar, uh,
on a sand street, uh,
in Lower Manhattan.
Uh,
that figure it seems to
metamorphose, uh, into, uh,
well Whitman in the,
a section for Cape Hatteras in a sense,
the center of the poem,
a Cape Hatteras, uh,
is concerned with, um,
the invention of flight. Uh, and, uh,
uh, at links a Whitman, um, to, um,
uh, well, really a, the whole
history of, uh, American, uh,
invention. Uh, there are, uh,
a series of songs called
three songs. Um, uh,
another section called
Quaker hill, uh, evoking, um,
in 1920s, um, uh,
New York suburb, a really
or, or Connecticut Hills, uh,
which, um, uh, brings
us up to the present,
uh, as does the poem, uh, the tunnel,
the tunnel being that most closely
based on the wasteland, uh,
and describing a kind of infernal
journey through the New York subways.
Uh, and then finally, um,
uh, Atlantis, uh, a
kind of a visionary, uh,
rhapsody that invokes the, uh, uh,
object of quest that the
poem is concerned with. Uh,
the poem as a,
in this way charts various journeys,
a westward and eastward,
uh,
back and forth in time.
Um,
discovery means nothing without the
relaying of the vision and the kind of
carrying it forward.
Um,
the bridge is a concerned with in these
various sections with a series of,
of, um, well a series of symbols,
symbols that are very frequently
vehicles or transports,
uh, from, uh, Columbus's ship to, uh,
the subway to the Wright
brothers, uh, airplanes,
uh, transport. Uh, this is in the sense,
the grand theme of the bridge.
Uh,
the root meaning of metaphor is to
carry something over to transport it.
A crane is, is, uh, um,
for crane metaphor is as
central, um, a concept,
inactivity, uh, as
translation is for pound.
But in a crane,
the emphasis is on
imaginative transformation.
That's really what a
metaphor has to offer. Uh,
the central symbol of the bridge. The
bridge itself, you could understand as a,
as a metaphor for metaphor,
a metaphor for a primary
human capacity. Uh, uh,
the capacity to posit an object of desire,
frosted eyes. There were
that lifted altars, uh,
to posit an object of desire that
expands the horizon of the real,
what's possible.
Uh,
and in so doing a violates a existing
systems of cognition and projects the
vision of a new world.
Uh,
this also means that the poem is
constantly producing new symbols for this
activity. New Metaphors,
uh, Crane said at a,
in one letter of the bridge in
becoming a ship, a world, a woman,
a tremendous harp as it finally does,
seems really to have a career.
Uh,
and so it does, um, this is, um,
again, the Black Sun edition,
which I recommend that you
go to buy Nikki. And look,
it's one of the most beautiful
books. Uh, I know, uh,
it's a great big book with
these, uh, big margins, uh, and,
uh, read, um, uh, headings.
Uh, let's look at the pro.
Um, uh, as both an introduction
to the poem and as a,
a kind of a summary, uh, in,
in miniature of it's a
intentions, uh, claims procedures.
How many dawn's chill from his rippling
rest the seagulls wings shall dip and
pivot him shedding white rings of
tumult building high over the chain,
Bay waters,
liberty.
Then with inviolate curve,
for sake our eyes as apparitional,
as sales that cross some page of figures
to be filed away till elevators drop us
from our day.
And the poem begins with another,
a resurrection of some kind in this case,
not a seal rising from the
water to a gaze toward paradise,
but rather a seagull,
uh,
rising as many times before,
how many dawn's chill from
his rippling rest. Uh,
and this, this seagull
becomes a kind of, um, uh,
image of a cent, uh, and, and flight, uh,
uh, the, the, I guess, uh, um, uh, it,
it is an initial image of transport.
Uh,
the bird sheds white rings of tumult,
uh,
and there's that word
from voyage is three.
You remember him where death
if shed presumes no carnage,
but the single change here, uh, again,
there's an action of shedding as the
bird throws off the darkness of the night
and rises, uh, building hi, uh,
then disappears.
The vision vanishes.
We're in the world of work.
Uh,
we are in the office spaces of lower
Manhattan till elevators drop us from our
day. And if we've just gone
up, now we go down again.
I think of cinemas,
panoramic slights with multitudes
bent towards some flashing scene.
Never disclosed,
but hasten to again for
told two other eyes.
On the same screen. Uh, the movie theater,
the movie theater is a new machine
of transport, uh, in the 20s.
A kind of mass entertainment
that cranes poem will in a sense,
try to rival and provide, uh, a, uh,
uh, complementary, uh, uh, way of, uh,
imagining a collective
vision, uh, anyone he offers.
Next is the bridge, uh, which he, uh,
addresses in this Archaic Language,
uh,
archaic and intimate language as if,
Brooklyn Bridge could have
a subjectivity and the,
he says across the harbor silver paste,
as if
the light on the bridge, uh, um,
we're being seen as a kind of movement
that the bridge was itself involved in,
uh,
as though the son took step of the yet
left some motion ever unspent in Nice
stride, implicitly thy freedom
staying the, uh, this is,
uh, this is a wild kind of address to, uh,
architecture, uh, as if the
bridge were animate, uh,
with the power of motion,
uh,
and as if it had a kind of
motion that was w fountain, like,
and could not be exhausted,
then suddenly were given another,
uh, vision. Uh,
the, um, uh,
the threat of suicide suddenly rises up
in the poem out of some subway scuttle
cell or loft,
a bedlam.
Mites speeds to thy parapets tilting
their momently shrill shirt ballooning
adjust falls from the speechless caravan.
Uh,
the possibility of failure
seems dialectically to be
written into this poem's
grant, uh, ambition.
Uh, it's, it's, um, uh,
it's
wish for a assent and,
and redemption, uh, crane, uh,
turns then, uh, two, uh,
images of, of the, uh,
of the, of the bridge in, uh,
the New York skyline down wall
from girder into street noon leaks,
a rip tooth of the skies,
a settling all afternoon the cloud flown
Derek's turn thigh cables breathe the
North Atlantic still as if it
were a kind of ship. Uh, I,
I don't know about you, but I, I, uh,
am thrilled every time I
read a crane's, um, uh,
language, uh, of evoking the, uh,
the kind of sensual power, uh, of,
uh, New York architecture. Oh,
harp and alter of the fury fused.
How could mirror toil align?
I quiring strings.
It's the bridges harp and alter
instrument of music and site of worship.
Terrific threshold of the profits.
Pledge Prayer of pariah and the lovers cry
again.
The traffic lights that Skim,
Nice unfractionated idiom,
immaculate sigh of stars beating thy path,
condense Aternity.
And we have seen night lifted in nine
arms under the eye shadow by the peers.
I waited only in darkness.
Is Eye shadow clear the city's
fiery parcels all undone already.
Snow submerges in Iron Year.
Oh,
sleepless is the river under the vaulting.
The see the prayer dreaming Saad.
Suddenly the bridge crosses the
Atlantic. It crosses, uh, the, uh,
American continent unto us lowliest
and now it's a kind of divinity that he
beseeches to descend and of the curb ship
of the bridge itself seen as a kind of
vehicle of a curved ship.
Lend a myth to God.
Uh,
the poem,
the poem means to, uh, incorporate, uh,
the threat of failure
and the threat of death,
uh, and move beyond it, uh,
much as it aims to incorporate,
um,
the wastelands despair and move beyond it.
Uh, it is, uh,
kind of just a kind of prayer,
a kind of pledge that
belongs to lover or pariah.
Um, these are our speech acts that, um,
our models for the kind of
poem that you're reading,
uh,
the intention is to somehow create from
a series of fragments a hole that would
be an unfractionated
idiom as crane calls it,
which would be a kind of
pure and redeemed language.
Uh,
there's that phrase in the
last stanza of the curve ship,
meaning, uh, both derived
from the bridge. Uh,
I think an in partaking of it,
uh,
he asks the Bridge to lend a myth
to God land, you know, to land is,
is to, uh, give, knowing
it will be given back. Uh,
this is not a permanent, uh, name for
God. It is not the one symbol for God.
It is only a one in an ongoing
series of acts of naming,
which are all acts of metaphor,
uh, which are all acts by which,
uh, something from the past
is joined to the future.
Something far as joined with something
near out of some kind of spiritual need
or vision. Well, the poem was, uh,
begun, uh, crane. Like this
idea both ends at once.
Just the way you build a bridge,
uh,
by writing the poem and by writing
a Atlantis and gradually, uh,
over time, uh, moving
towards, uh, the middle. Um,
the, um, this is, uh,
the final section, uh,
Atlantis. In fact, why don't we
turn there for a moment? Uh, this,
this is this kind of
splendid, outrageous, um,
uh, Shelly in a lyric speech, uh,
through the bound cable strands, the
arching path upward veering with light,
the flight of strings.
And you can image now, uh,
in your minds that great Stella
painting, um, over in the gallery,
uh,
taught miles of shuttling moonlights
syncopate the whispered rush telepathy of
wires up the index of night granted and
steel transparent meshes fleck lists the
gleaming staves sibling voices,
flicker wavering Lee
stream as though a god.
We're issue of the strings here.
Uh,
at the end of the poem,
a crane imagines a kind of a cent,
uh,
through the structure of the bridge,
which becomes a grand musical instrument,
a harp.
Um, the, uh, uh, visionary,
uh, appears here, uh,
in fragmentary ways as in line 25 where
a sheerly the eyes like seagulls stung
with rhyme, uh, slipped and propelled
by glistening fins of light.
A crane talks here about
the eyes moving up, uh,
through this structure.
Uh,
like the seagull that we saw
in the first line of the poem.
Um, the, the,
the object of desire,
the, the, uh, uh, uh,
version of paradise crane offers us.
Is there an in line 42 or so,
uh,
where he talks about the bridge as vision
of the voyage bridge lifting night to
Cyclorama mic.
It should be a crest of deepest day,
uh,
oh choir translating time
into what multitudinous verb,
the suns and synergy of waters ever fuse
as if somehow the sun and water on the
space of the,
uh,
bridge and beneath it a created what crane
calls a multitudinous verb recast and
myriad syllables,
some of cafe.
That's of course Columbus's
goal cafe. Um, oh,
love thy White Pervasive Paradigm.
It's also a vision of love.
Um,
here, um, crane gives us a
kind of vision of the word,
the multitudinous verb as what his poem,
uh,
draws its a energy from and
what it moves towards. A,
it is not a Christian
word. Uh, importantly,
uh, it is, it is I think a a name for,
for a creative process that accessed
in and through our powers of language.
The word in cranes pump,
uh,
is secular and historical,
but yet it unfolds from what he
calls an ever presence beyond time.
A towards which the poem
is, is questing. Uh,
it is, uh, uh,
creativity or kind of power of world
making a that's embodied in our language
crane is imagining a post
Christian religion, uh,
for which America provides
iconography and myths. Uh,
the poem is it an encyclopedia of
America and places in American culture,
uh, popular culture, uh,
in, in, uh, in burlesque,
in national winter garden in the
river in Virginia. There's slang,
jazz advertising.
All of that worked into the poem.
Uh,
the palm combines I kind of popular
storybook history of figures like Rip Van
Winkle and, uh, the most challenging
abstract modernist poetics.
At the same time. Uh, every
line is, is loaded with,
uh,
symbols and reference linking up
to other lines in the same way.
Uh,
in the same way crane is suggesting that
every moment in American history links
up with others, uh, and with the
larger structure of action, uh,
of which it is part a
crane's poem is therefore,
uh, I think, uh,
at once knowingly naive and hyper
sophisticated, uh, both of these,
uh,
things at once.
Um, crane composed the poem, uh,
through the funding with
the funding of Otto Kahn,
a businessman, philanthropist, uh,
and he explains his outline
of the poem, uh, at, um,
uh,
still a relatively early
period of composition in
that letter to Otto Kahn that
I included for you last time. Um, he, uh,
uh, well I'll just, uh, I'll,
I'll refer to it. Um, uh,
briefly, uh, the, um, uh,
keeping mind that table of
contents. I, I showed you before,
there's a kind of story of
American history told in large,
uh,
or in,
in the poem in which
crane moves from Columbus
to, uh, the, uh, um,
the section called Po,
Po Hatton's daughter, uh, where the
theme is the betrayal of the land, uh,
in the conquest of the
continent. Uh, in the middle, uh,
in, in Cape Hatteras, uh, when crane is,
is writing about a invention
and technology, uh,
in American culture,
his theme is also the civil
war and World War One.
Uh,
again,
a kind of a betrayal of vision by which
technology becomes a means to kill.
Uh, in, um, his letter to con, uh,
he talks about having a section on John
Brown that would take up the topic of
slavery. Uh, this section
was never written,
but there are traces of it you find
in the section called the river.
Uh, in each of these sections,
uh, crane turns to, uh, and,
and looks to, um, um, uh, again,
hobos marginal figures who are,
uh,
emblems of lost promise who,
um,
uh,
seem to represent
possibilities,
uh,
included in but also marginalized by,
American history,
American culture.
You can understand these figures such as
the sailor that you meet and cutty Sark
as versions of the authors to whom crane
appeals throughout through illusion and
epigraph. Melville, uh, Dickinson,
a Po in the tunnel,
uh,
crane reaches back to these
authors canonical for us,
Co authors that you study,
but that were, uh, uh,
largely left out of accounts of American
literary history in the 1920s who
themselves appeared to be
marginals. Um, these, uh,
these are our versions
of a kind of, um, uh,
community that crane wants to
recover and carry forward, uh,
for the, uh, creative promise
that they seem to embody.
Well, um, let me, um,
okay.
Just point to, uh, the poems.
Let's say a two different
endings. Um, the, uh,
okay.
History of the composition of the
poem is different from the uh, uh,
sequence, uh, that you read. Uh,
because crane began at both ends.
Uh,
the end of the poem is really
a, in one sense, the middle.
Uh, when Crane Completes Cape
Hatteras at last, after, um,
uh, struggling, uh, with this
section, uh, for a couple years,
um, he, um, uh, completes, uh,
the span of the bridge in
one, uh, particular, uh, uh,
image one, 1 cents. And that's, uh,
towards the end of the
section on six 36. Uh, and he,
he invokes a in quotes,
Whitman, Whitman, again, a, uh,
here, seen as a kind of a marginal, uh,
who is a recovered for American
culture through the poems,
uh, imaginative act. Um,
Whitman is addressed, recorders,
ages, hence that's a quote from,
from Whitman's Calamus poems,
uh, recorders ages. Hence, yes,
they shall hear in their own veins
on canceled thy Shore Tread Whitman,
uh, and read the by the
oral, the halo round.
I head of pasture shine.
Panis Angelica,
a bread of angels. Uh,
here, uh, uh, Whitman's, um,
Whitman becomes a kind of figure for,
um, uh, a kind of secular communion.
Yes, Walt afoot again and
onward without halt. Not soon,
nor suddenly know, never to let
go my hand in yours, Walt Whitman.
So, uh, that is,
that's a kind of a moment
when in this hand clasp, uh,
a certain, um, uh,
aspiration of the poem, uh,
is completed, uh, and, and
a connection, uh, to, uh,
the past is a achieved, uh, in assertive.
The conclusion of the
poem that we find in, um,
uh, uh, at the end of
Atlantis, uh, is, is another,
uh, vision. Uh, and
I'll conclude with that.
Um, it's, I think, uh,
something to be contrasted with
this triumphant and reassuring,
um,
conclusion that a Cape
Hatteras offers, uh, here.
Well,
here are the last to
sublime stanza of the poem migrations
that must needs void memory inventions
that cobblestone the heart
unspeakable bow bridge to the Oh,
love the, I pardon for this
history, widest flower. Oh,
answer of all anemone.
Now while the pedal, the
sun's about as hold, oh,
thou whose radio and stuff inherit me.
It Lantis hold dye
floating singer late here,
Atlantis is brought into being with,
uh,
the singer himself on
the verge of drowning
I floating singer. And
then finally, uh, uh,
crane dedicates himself
to this, uh, vision,
which he calls ever presence.
So to design ever presence beyond time,
like spears in sanguine of one tolling
star that bleeds infinity the or fix
strings.
Now the cables of the bridge have
become the strings of Orpheus is liar.
Say Dariel. Phalynx is leap
and converge. And again,
you can see the structure of the
bridge image there. One Song,
one bridge of fire,
is it cafe now pity steeps the grass
and rainbows ring the serpent with the
eagles in the leaves whispers
and Tiffany in Azure swing.
The poem ends, uh, with
this question. Is it cafe
Columbus's question,
uh, an error, a mistake.
Uh, it is the nature of the
object of desire to be misnamed,
uh, precisely because
it has no one name. Uh,
and even in this a error,
this kind of a defeat, um,
there is for crane,
uh,
in affirming of the scope of desire
precisely through its failure to be
contained by a single reference.
Well,
we'll stop now. Um,
and, uh, I know you have
done your work and, and gathered
a, a, a, a note a wheel, um,
collect these, uh, and, um, uh,
put together our own
annotated version of the poem.